The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So these are the
scores from test number two.
The celebration.
And as you can see, the
average has gone down.
So as I've said in the past, I
think everybody in this room
has the intellectual capacity
to be here.
Some people choose
to be there.
I don't know why they choose to
be there, why they choose
not to go to recitation, why
they choose not to try the
homework, why they choose not
to go to office hours, why
they choose not to read.
But I guarantee you,
when you make that
choice you will be here.
And I have no requirements
whatsoever to pass a certain
number of people.
I can give everybody
A's if I want.
And I can take a large number
of people-- you
know, look at this.
The way this is right now,
the failure rate will be
abnormally high.
So I would warmly recommend that
if you're down here, that
you look in the mirror and ask
yourself a few questions.
OK.
Let's get to the lesson.
We're going to start
a new unit today.
The new unit is going to be
the second half of the
classification of solids.
We looked at solids and we
reasoned that there were
ordered solids and we've looked
at crystals and their
arrangements and so on.
And today, we're going
to start talking
about disordered solids.
And they're characterized
by no long-range order.
They have short-range order.
You might know who your next
nearest neighbor is, or your
second next nearest neighbor,
but you certainly don't know
who your 10th nearest neighbor
is or who your 100th nearest
neighbor is.
And these solids are called
amorphous solids.
And there's a simple
one salable
Angle-Saxon word for this.
It's called glass.
So we're going to talk
about glasses.
What kind of materials
can form glasses?
Well, obviously, materials
that have trouble
crystallizing.
And they come from a variety
of walks of life.
So we have in organic
compounds.
Some inorganic compounds can
form disordered solids.
And a good example
is silicates.
And this is what you know as
window glass, glass that's
used in bottles, cookware,
and so on.
There are organic compounds
that can form disordered
solids and a variety
of polymers.
Things like food wrap and so on,
are also prone to forming
disordered solids.
Some elements.
Some simple elements can
form disordered solids.
A good example is sulfur.
Sulfur can form solid in
crystalline form, but more
often than not, it can form
disordered solids.
And what I'm going to show you
towards the end of the lecture
is metal alloys.
Metal alloys can form disordered
solids, and you're
going to see metallic glasses.
And they're typically 80%
metal and 20% metalloid.
That is somewhere along that red
staircase on your Periodic
Table that divides the metals
from the nonmetals.
So a good example here
is iron 80--
this is on mole basis--
and boron 20, boron being
the metalloid.
And some, some do both.
Some compounds can form both
crystal and amorphous.
So one example of that
is SiO2, silica.
When it forms crystalline solid,
we call it quartz.
Crystalline SiO2 is quartz,
and amorphous SiO2 is the
silicate glass that we know
for windows and bottles.
And so as I've said many times,
the term "glass" is
related to atomic arrangement.
It has nothing to do
with the ability
to see through something.
Transparency has
no place here.
So what are the conditions?
I mean, if you have silica and
it can form crystalline or
amorphous forms, how does
it decide which to do?
And so I'm going to
look at conditions
promoting glass formation.
And I'm going to form glasses
on the basis of
solidification.
So I'm going to start from the
liquid and go to the solid.
So I'm asking the question, why,
on some occasions, does
the liquid go to a solid that's
amorphous and in other
occasions it will go to a solid
that is crystalline?
As in the case of quartz.
So there are primarily three
factors that it boils down to.
And I like to make the analogy
to the game of musical chairs.
So imagine I've got chairs
placed around
this central table.
You know how the game goes.
There are more people
than chairs.
And the music starts and you
walk around, and then at some
point the music stops and people
race for the chairs.
And some people are going to get
a seat and they get booted
out of the game.
And then one of the chairs is
removed and then so it goes.
You know this game.
I know you don't want to admit
to playing it, but your little
siblings play it.
But of course, you
don't play it.
But imagine if you
were to play it.
The same situation here.
I've got silicate floating
around in the liquid state,
and the chairs are the crystal
lattice sites.
So the question is, what
promotes the ability to get to
the lattice sites or not?
So obviously, one of the
first things we think
about is atom mobility.
Atom or compound mobility.
This is in the liquid phase.
And the way I want to write
this, I want to talk about
promoting glass formation.
So obviously, high mobility is
going to enhanced crystal
formation, isn't it?
If you've got high mobility,
you're going to be able to
find the right lattice site.
So I'm going to talk about
if atom mobility promotes
crystallization, the reciprocal
of atom mobility
will promote glass formation.
The second thing is the
arrangement of the chairs.
If the chairs are in a simple
line, it's easy
to get to the chairs.
All other things being equal.
But if the chairs are arranged
in some complex formation,
it's harder to get
to the chairs.
So that has an analogy and
that's the complexity of the
crystal structure.
The more complex,
the more likely
you are to form glasses.
And then the last thing, an
analogy to the musical chairs,
is the rate at which
the music stops.
If the music stops suddenly you
could get trapped in the
liquid state.
If I gradually turn down
the volume, you
know, OK, wait a minute.
The music's going to stop.
You start moving towards
the seat.
So that's the analogy.
Here is the cooling rate.
So a high cooling rate is
going to make it more
difficult for the system to
find the crystal structure
because as the cooling starts,
the atoms start thinking, gee,
it's time to form the solid.
But the thermal energy is
removed from the system before
the atoms have had a chance to
find a crystal structure.
So the reciprocal of atom
mobility, we write in a
positive term and call
that the viscosity.
Something, a fluid, a liquid,
that has low atom mobility has
high viscosity.
So I'll take this out and
instead represent it this way.
This is the way to think
about the formation of
the amorphous state.
And why are we studying
glasses?
Well, in the old days it was
bottles and food and
cook ware and so on.
Today, fiber optics.
Fiber optics is based on
silicate chemistry.
Very important.
So understanding silicate
chemistry has high-tech
implications.
So let's look at, for the first
study, the silicates.
The silicates for their value
in fiberoptic technology.
So these are based on SiO2.
And some nomenclature.
This is called silica.
So the oxide of an atom is named
by adding the term "a."
So silicon gives us silica
as the oxide.
So here's the atom silicon,
the basic element.
And if we fully oxidize--
see, here I've taken silicon, I
put two oxygens, so I made a
neutral compound--
that's silica.
And then if I fully oxidize--
the maximum number of oxygens
I can put around is four--
and this is going to have
a net charge of 4 minus.
And this fully oxidized anion
is called the silicate.
And that's where we get the name
of the family of glasses.
So this is fully oxidized.
So now let's look at
the structure.
Silicate glasses.
sp3 hybridized.
Just like carbon above it.
So that gives us the four struts
off of the central
silicon at 109 degree angles
to one another.
And let's put some flesh
on the bones here.
So I'll put a silicon
here in the center.
One, two, three, four.
But instead of putting silicons
everywhere, I'll put
oxygens at the end
of the struts.
And then I'll put the second
silicon, and you can see the
oxygen is acting as a bridge
between the two silicons.
One, two, three, four.
Let's do one more.
Another silicon.
One, two, three, four.
So again, you can see the
oxygen acts as a bridge
between the two silicons.
So you see four oxygens per
silicon, but I've got two
silicons per oxygen.
Hence, the structure looks
like SiO4, but the
stoichiometry of the
compound is SiO2
because the oxygens bridge.
So this doesn't give you any
clue as to what the structure
should be, does it?
You really have to write
this thing out.
Now, here's where the thing
gets interesting.
This is a three-dimensional
network.
All of these oxygens
bridge to silicons.
And I was talking here
about viscosity.
You can see that this thing in
the liquid state is huge.
It's like a giant battleship,
and this is just one.
So now we can have
another silicate.
It can form chains.
It can form meshes.
And these meshes entangle.
So viscosity very high.
So when it goes to solidify--
David, if we can go to the
document camera, please--
so here you see the silicate.
So the yellows represent
silicon.
And you can see the
oxygens, here, are
at 109 degree angles.
So this is the SiO4.
We'll do some nanotechnology
here.
So here's the SiO4.
One, two, three, four.
And now I'm going to
make the bridge.
But look.
The bond between the oxygens and
the silicon is defined in
three dimensions.
It's a 109 degree angle.
But the bond between the two
oxygens is not defined.
It's only defined in
two dimensions.
So you can see that if I put
all of these oxygens on the
same plane--
so somebody borrowed this
and look, they lost
an oxygen for me.
Got a missing oxygen, here.
If you find this thing, please
bring it to my office.
So now all five oxygens
are on the same plane.
One, two, three,
four, and five.
And then up here are
the two silicons.
They're in the same plane.
The oxygens are in
the same plane.
What I'm showing you here
is the beginning
of crystalline quartz.
Crystalline quartz,
this stuff.
But now what happens
if we cool quickly?
This bond is only specified in
two dimensions, which means I
can hold this bond at
the proper value and
this is free to rotate.
This is free to rotate.
Look at the autofocus
on this thing.
Who designed this?
Boy, what a stupid machine.
So anyway, so here we are.
Here is the point.
This bond is free to rotate,
and when it rotates, look--
now this oxygen is no longer in
the plane with this oxygen.
And as a result of that freedom
to rotate, we can end
up running out of
thermal energy.
And this is nowhere near its
regular crystalline array.
So this gives you the
indications of the high
viscosity, moderate cooling rate
will end up giving you
the amorphous silica.
But in all cases, this bond
is the linkage through.
So we end up with this
three-dimensional network.
So what do we do with to
show that we have some
evidence for this?
David, may we cut back to
the slides, please?
So how do you characterize?
I'm going to use x-rays.
So here's an x-ray diffraction
pattern of the-- the upper one
is cristobalite, which is
one of the polymorphs of
crystalline SiO2.
And you can see you have
distinct peaks indicative of
satisfying Bragg's Law.
There's some width to
them, but that's
because it's a real crystal.
Down here, this is the
amorphous silica.
You don't see all of
these features.
You see only one very
broad peak.
Now if I said it's crystal--
pardon me-- if it's glass, you'd
say, well, it has no
long-range order.
So why do we have even
this one feature?
What's this one feature
indicative of?
Doesn't matter how much disorder
there is, I still
know that no matter what, I'm
always going to have these
four oxygens as my nearest
neighbors.
So these four oxygens minus any
long-range order gives us
this one line here.
So we have evidence for it.
Now let's look at the
energetics, because clearly,
these are two different
states.
One of these is lower energy
than the other.
Which one is it?
How to think about
the problem?
There's a simple way
to do it with the
tools we have in 3.091.
Energetics can be given
by bond formation.
Energetics via bond density.
When things form bonds
the energy
of the system decreases.
So which one is going to have
higher bond density?
Well, the higher bond density
clearly is going to be
exhibited by the one that
has the tighter packing.
And which one has
tighter packing?
The disordered solid or
the ordered solid?
The ordered solid has much
more dense packing.
So the ordered crystal exhibits
tighter packing,
therefore, this means more
bonds per unit volume.
So that means, to me, that the
energy of the crystalline
state must be more negative
than the energy
of the glassy state.
That makes sense so far.
But now I want to show you one
other thing that we've just
inferred from this
little exercise.
If we get more bonds per unit
volume, then can you see that
we've made an association
between the binding energy of
any arbitrary ensemble and
it's molar volume?
So volume now, is a very easy
thing to measure, isn't it?
You can see it with
the naked eye.
So the volume of something with
a given composition--
and we're talking about a mole,
we're talking about
equal numbers of atoms--
so the molar volume is
indicative of binding energy.
It's a one-to-one
correspondence.
If you like, the Vmolar is a
measure of disorder, meaning
the higher the molar volume,
the greater the disorder.
Or put the other way, the
smallest molar volume is that
exhibited by the crystal.
So we have some traces here that
come from the reading.
So this comes from the archival
lecture notes that
were written by my predecessor,
Professor Witt.
There's a little typo here that
obviously heating means
increasing temperature, not
decreasing temperature.
Make a little correction here.
So what we're plotting is the
volume, the molar volume of
silicate glass as a function
of temperature.
And imagine we start with
some blob of glass--
of some known mass--
so we can divide and figure out
what the molar volume is,
and we started cooling it.
We cool down until we get
to the crystallization
temperature of quartz.
And when we get to that
temperature crystalline quartz
forms and along with
it, a tremendous
decrease in the volume.
Unlike water ice, which is a
rare exception, where the ice
occupies a larger volume than
the liquid, for most systems,
the solid is more compact
than the liquid.
And that's what you see here.
There's an abrupt drop here
at the melting point.
And then when we continue to
cool, there's some thermal
contraction.
And as you can imagine a hot
solid occupies a greater
volume than a cold solid.
And so this is the cooling curve
and you can retrace it,
heat up, and when we get to the
melting point, there's a
tremendous expansion
and then off we go.
So that's the classical form
of the crystallization of a
material that is undergoing the
normal process of liquid
to solid transformation.
I'm going to use some
tea colors today.
So we went down the red line.
Now let's go down
the green line.
So we're going to go down
We go down the green line, we're
going to use the same
stuff, this silicate network,
only we're going to cool a
little bit faster.
And we cool a little bit faster,
we can zoom right on
past the normal melting
point and create
a supercooled liquid.
And that supercooled liquid
gets lower and lower in
temperature and all the while
the volume is shrinking.
Again, a hot liquid what
occupies a smaller volume than
cold liquid.
You know this from a mercury--
the old days, you remember
these old thermometers?
You probably have never seen
one of these things.
It's all done digitally.
But we used to have these liquid
and bulb thermometers.
You'd have numbers on here,
and what happens is the
temperature goes up, the liquid
in here rises to a
higher temperature.
And at a lower temperature
this contracts.
Isn't the solid expanding,
too?
Uh-huh.
So what's the other thing
you learned from this?
It must mean that coefficient of
thermal expansion, which we
affectionately will call CTE,
the coefficient of thermal
expansion of the liquid, must
be much greater than the
coefficient of the thermal
expansion of a solid.
Otherwise, the two would expand
and you wouldn't get
any sensible measurement
out of this, right?
Well, we see that on a curve.
We see that on a curve, because
when we plot volume
versus temperature, when we're
up here in the liquid regime
we have a steep slope.
This slope here is dv by dt.
And when we get down on
the solid regime,
it's a gradual slope.
It's still a slope, but it's
a gradual because the
coefficient of thermal
expansion down
here is very low.
And that's what you're
seeing here.
So at some temperature the
system changes from a
supercooled liquid to a solid.
But it's a disordered solid
because we've quenched in all
of that remaining
liquid disorder.
And take a look at this--
you've changed from the slope
that's characteristic of the
coefficient of thermal expansion
of a liquid down
here to the gentle slope
coefficient of thermal
expansion of solid.
You know what this proves?
This proves that glass
is a solid.
There are many people out there,
even in the popular
press, who will say, glass
is just a very,
very viscous liquid.
Nonsense.
Look at this.
It has this coefficient
of thermal expansion.
And don't fall for any of that
nonsense they tell you when
you go to the cathedrals in
Europe and the glass is
thicker at the bottom because
it's been dripping for 400
years, and that proves--
you know why the glass is
thicker at the bottom?
Because they made
it by spinning.
And when they spun it, it was
graded in thickness from the
center out.
And now, if you're the glazier
and you're putting the glass
in a window, which way would you
put a pane of glass that
had variable thickness?
Would you put the thickest
part up or the
thickest part down?
It's thicker on the bottom
because that's
the way it was made.
Lord help the tour guide when
there's an MIT student taking
3.091 on that tour.
All right, so here we are.
Look at what you have here?
You see this?
At this temperature--
let's say down here where
the lines end, it's room
temperature.
At room temperature
the volume of the
crystalline solid is low.
The volume of the amorphous
solid is higher.
That's proving this.
Vmolar is a measure
of the disorder.
And sure enough, the glass that
was cooled quickly ends
up quenching in more of the
liquid state disorder, and you
see that in terms of what I
call the excess volume.
The excess volume is a measure
disorder because the
crystalline solid
non-zero volume.
So we can define, we can go from
this directly over and
say that v, that's
the excess--
that's a pun.
You know, instead
of writing this?
This is the way they
do in high school.
This is the excess volume.
Bologna.
We don't write like that.
Excess volume is equal
to v of the glass
minus v of the crystal.
And the greater the excess
volume, the greater the degree
of disorder.
So let's do one more.
Let's go down the orange line.
The projector isn't giving us a
good yellow component, here.
OK, so this is the
orange line.
And what's the difference
between the orange line and
the green line?
The difference between the
orange line and the green line
is that in the orange line
we're going to cool more
slowly than we did on
the green line.
Because green means go.
So that's the fast one, right?
So here we are.
We still get supercooled liquid,
but we get down to a
lower temperature before we have
ceased to have higher and
higher viscous liquid and
have formed the solid.
The knee in that curve occurs
at a lower temperature.
And that value is called the
glass transition temperature.
Why do we call it the glass
transition temperature instead
of just saying it's a
solidification temperature?
Because when I say
solidification, before today
you would say, OK, liquid
became a solid.
But after today, if someone says
to you, solidification,
you say, do mean ordered solid
or disordered solid?
So we distinguish.
So every crystallization is a
solidification, but every
solidification is not
a crystallization.
So here we are.
Look at this-- this has a
smaller excess volume.
Because if it was a slower
cooling, that meant that's the
equivalent of giving more time,
more thermal energy, for
things to find their crystalline
position, which
means there's less excess
volume quenched in.
OK.
So let's just get that down,
define these things.
So this is a measure
of disorder.
Or glassiness, if you like.
OK.
So now let's define these two
different temperatures so that
we have the distinction.
So we have, first of all, the
classical one, which is
crystallization.
And crystallization represents
the reactions of liquid.
In both cases, we're going to
convert a liquid to a solid,
but a liquid goes to a
crystalline solid.
And that occurs at a
unique temperature
called the melting point.
Imagine if I talked
to you about the
freezing point of water.
Freezing point of water at
atmospheric pressure is 0
degrees centigrade.
If I asked you, well, if I cool
the water really quickly
or if I cool it slowly, does it
make any difference to the
freezing point of water?
No.
Why not?
Why isn't all this happening?
Because water is a tiny molecule
and so cooling rate
has no impact on the temperature
of conversion.
Those water molecules
will always find
their lattice sites.
So this is a function
only of composition.
If I put something in the water
and I make it impure, I
know I can change its
freezing point.
If I put salt in water, I will
depress its freezing point.
But if I put pure water, it
will free at 0 degrees
centigrade.
Later on, we'll learn that
there are some pressure
effects, but today that's not
going to elucidate anything.
It'll just be a distraction.
So pure water, always
the same thing.
But now if you go to something
like silica, which has the
capability of forming a glass,
the glass formation is a
different reaction.
Glass formation is written
in this manner.
We will start with supercooled
liquid.
It's liquid, but I'm already
going to stipulate that it's
liquid that's been cooled
below the melting point.
Supercooled means it's
cooled below the
normal melting point.
So a supercooled liquid is going
to form a glassy solid,
and this occurs at tg.
tg, which is the glass
transition temperature.
And that is very much a function
of cooling rate.
And, of course, the function
of composition.
Obviously, if we change the
composition from SiO2, we're
no longer comparing
apples to apples.
So composition is important in
both instances, but only in
the case of supercooled liquid
do we form the glassy solid.
And the degree of disorder
is a function
of the cooling rate.
And how is it a function
of the cooling rate?
As the dt by dt, right?
Change in temperature with time
as dt by dt goes up, the
degree of disorder goes up.
So if I want to quench in the
liquid state, can you imagine
if I had liquid and I could
instantaneously cool it?
I would quench in all of
the liquid disorder.
If I quench it less rapidly,
there will be some time for
the atoms to strive for a
degree of crystallinity.
So all of this we've said with
reference to silicate glasses.
Now, there are other glasses.
What are other glass
forming oxides?
Well, what do I have
to look for?
I should look for other
compounds that form bridging
oxygens, right?
That's the key here.
What's the unifying feature?
It's bridging oxygens.
Bridging oxygen leads
to glass formation.
So what are other compounds
that could give us such
bridging oxygens?
Well, you could be lazy and say,
well, if silica does it,
then why don't I look up
and down the column
on a Periodic Table.
If you go up to carbon that's no
good because it forms gas,
but if you go underneath you
will form germania glasses.
So this is germania, and the
glasses are germinate glasses.
You can also go to
group three.
B2O3.
B2O3 forms sp2 hybrids.
And the sp2 hybrids
off of each boron,
we have three oxygens.
And that oxygen can bond
to another boron.
One, two, three.
And this is all going to lie
flat in a plane, isn't it?
But this oxygen bridge is only
specified in two dimensions,
whereas the boron struts are
specified in three dimensions,
which means this oxygen bond
between the two borons doesn't
have to lie in the plane.
It could tilt this up and if it
does, this is going to have
a greater volume.
You can see this with
the naked eye.
I mean, I could have just taught
the lessen by putting
this slide up.
If those are equivalent numbers
of borons and oxygens,
it's plainly obvious that on
the right side you've got
excess volume.
This occupies a much larger
volume than the
image to the left.
The image to the left
is crystalline B2O3.
The image to the right is the
same stuff, except in many
instances this
boron-oxygen-boron bond
doesn't lie in the plane.
It tilts out of the plane and
it causes all sorts of
distortions and leads
to excess volume.
So this is called
a borate glass.
All right, so if we can do it
with the borates, we can do it
with anything that will
form covalent bonds.
So we can do it with P2O5,
phosphate glasses.
V2O5, vanadate glasses.
As2O5, arsenate glasses.
And Sb2O5, stibnite glasses.
And these are used, actually,
as additives to some of the
glass that's put in computer
screens so that they will
gobble up excess oxygen on
cooling and avoid bubble
formation, which then makes
the glass foggy.
And a foggy computer screen is
no fun to try to look through.
So what are the properties
of these oxide glasses?
Well, first of all, they're
chemically inert.
Why are they chemically inert?
Because they've got strong
covalent bonds.
So if you try to react something
with them, it's
going to take a very
special compound
that can trigger reactions.
Which is why they're used for
bottling beverages and
packaging foods.
You put vegetables and fruits
in glass jars going back to
ancient times.
Until recent times, with the
advent of the soda can, there
were glass bottles and so.
They're electrically
insulating.
Why are they electrically
insulating?
Electronic structure.
These are all covalent bonds,
high band gap, which is why
the amorphous version is
used in window glass.
High band gap, which means
light goes through.
How do I think about whether
something is transparent?
Do a little finger
demonstration.
This is the band gap of the
glass, and this is the band
energy, the photon energy.
If the photon energy is small
it goes right through.
That's called transparency,
see.
You can study quantum mechanics,
but you know what?
This is it.
That's all you have to know.
Now what happens if the
band gap is small--
like around 2eV--
and here's the photon energy?
That's called absorption
and re-emission.
Transparency, absorption.
That's all it takes.
You think I'm kidding.
That's all you need to know.
So now, the next thing.
Mechanically brittle.
Why are they mechanically
brittle?
Strong bonds.
No opportunity for slip.
Please don't tell me-- this is
what students tell me every
year and they get zero for the
stupid answer-- that the
reason glass is brittle is it's
a distorted solid and
therefore has no dislocations.
Uh-uh.
Dislocations take the stress
required to cause slip and
reduce it to a lower value.
But you cannot cause this
thing to slip once it is
solidified.
The only way to get this silicon
to move relative to
that silicon in a
vertical shear--
let's say I want to make this
silicon move up and this
silicon move down-- there's
only one way.
It's called break that bond.
When you break that covalent
bond, that's called fracture.
So there is no slip allowed
because we have strong
covalent bonds.
If you want to reshape glass,
what do you have to do?
You have to heat it back up
above its glass transition
temperature.
But you do not shape glass
once it is solidified.
You may have tried in the home,
and then you end up with
something called shards.
And that's the reason.
Optically transparent, we
know that one already.
OK.
Last thing is the very
high melting.
Melting point of silica is over
1,500 degrees Celsius.
You're saying, well,
wait a minute.
He's telling me we're going to
make beverage containers,
we're going to make food
containers, we're going to
make all sorts of useful
objects, but that's going to
cost a lot of energy
to go away up there
to melt this glass.
But it does have desirable
properties--
chemically inert, and so on.
So what can we do?
Back here.
Glass transition temperate is a
function of cooling rate and
a function of composition.
So next step is let's modify
the composition of the
silicate network in order
to drop it's processing
temperature so that we can make
beverage containers at
acceptable energy.
So what's it going to take?
I'm going to have to do
something about those bonds.
Because those bonds are what
caused me to have to go to
such high temperatures.
So in order to reduce the
processing temperature of
silicate glasses via change
in composition--
so this is material science--
change the composition in
order to get desirable
properties.
And specifically, I want
to lower the processing
temperature.
Even when I get these things
liquid, they don't deform very
well, because all these networks
are entangled.
So I'll give you another
analogy.
Suppose you're in the kitchen
and you're going
to cook some pasta.
So you take some linguine and
it's about a foot long.
So you got this pound of
linguine and you cook it in
the boiling water and you
pour in into a colander.
And you may or may not rinse
it with cold water.
Whatever.
Just leave it in the colander
for a little while and what
you'll find is the whole thing
turns into one big mass.
I'm not talking about the
stuff got all gooey.
I'm just saying it just
hangs together.
And if you're clever you can
just gently slide it out.
And it'll slide out of
this one big mass.
What's holding those strands of
pasta together, by the way?
Well, are they covalent bonds?
Are they ionic bonds?
Are they metallic bonds?
I don't know, if you've got
metallic pasta, you've got
digestive problems. So
what's the bonds?
It's van der Waals
bonds, right?
Now, I can cause them to
slip again, can't I?
I can put a little
water in there.
And what does the water do?
It goes in between and then it's
got hydrogen bonds and
they slide.
I can put a little oil in there
and then that slides.
or.
The other thing I
could do is--
you know, have you ever seen
some people, they break the
pasta before they boil it?
I did this experiment.
So you take the pound,
divide it two halves.
By my math, that's
two half pounds.
So you cook the one half pound
one foot in length and you
cook the other half pound--
break them in three.
So they're about four-inchers.
And then you put them each
in a separate colander.
Which one do you think is
going to be much more
difficult to move around?
It's the long stuff, right?
The long stuff entangles.
So we're going to do the same
thing here with the
processing.
And basically, you can study
and learn pretty much
everything you need to know
about polymeric networks in
the kitchen with a
pound of pasta.
All you need to know.
All right, so let's
go and look at it.
I want to reduce the amount, the
length, of those chains.
If I reduce the length of those
chains, I can process at
much, much lower temperatures.
So what's my weapon, here?
My weapon here is oxygen.
Oxygen is going to go in there
in the form of the oxide ion.
And the oxide ion, O double
minus, has a very, very high
affinity for the bonding.
And so what'll happen is
oxide ion attacks the
oxygen-silicon bond.
It attacks the oxygen-silicon
bond and breaks it.
It breaks it in two and then
incorporates itself into the
network in the following way--
you see I have to silicons
joined across an oxygen?
This free oxide ion will come
in here, interrupt that
network in the following
manner.
So it's now broken the
silicon chain.
Now, I've got conservation
of charge.
This was 2 minus.
I don't see any exposed
charge here.
I need 2 minus.
This'll be minus 1, this'll
be minus 1.
I have conservation of charge,
I have conservation of mass.
And what I've done is I've
broken the chain.
This is called chain scission.
Shorter chains, higher
fluidity.
Higher fluidity, which means
lower processing temperature.
Now, where am I going
to get my--
I can't go to the lab and get
a bottle of oxide anions.
I have to have charged
neutral species.
And so what I'm going to look
for is an oxide ion donor.
I need an oxide ion donor.
And where do I find an
oxide ion donor?
Well, better be something
that's going to be a
cation, isn't it?
Because if I've got an oxide
anion, I need a cation.
And what kind of a cation?
How do I make an oxide anion?
I have to have electrons
to give to the oxygen.
So I need a good
electron donor.
Or to use a simple Anglo-Saxon
word, a good metal.
So a good metal oxide like,
say, calcium oxide.
So if I take calcium oxide and
I dissolve calcium oxide in
silica, it dissociates
to give calcium
cation plus oxide anion.
And then the oxide anion
migrates over here to our pal
the oxygen bridge and results in
two of these broken pieces.
So we call this one a bridging
oxygen, as I've been saying up
until now, BO.
And this one is called
a terminal oxygen.
This is bridging oxygen, this
is terminal oxygen.
Or some people, I
don't know why--
they have no literary skills--
they call it
non-bridging oxygen.
I hate that because it tells
you what it's not.
So you might see non-bridging
oxygen.
So all of these up here, the
silicates and so on, these
compounds that have the
ability to form oxygen
bridges, these are called
network formers.
These are all network formers.
Because they have the capacity
to make oxygen bridges.
And then compounds like calcium
oxide that have the
ability to donate oxide ions
that break bridges, these are
called network modifiers.
So good examples--
any good metal.
So I can look at lithium oxide,
sodium oxide, these
will all disassociate
to give oxide anion.
If calcium will work and you
believe Mendeleyev, then you
should probably think about
magnesium oxide, calcium
oxide, and anything
in that series.
A good ionic oxide like
lanthanum oxide, yttrium
oxide, these will be
oxide ion donors.
If you want to get yourself
fired, use scandium oxide
because it's frightfully
expensive.
And you can go to Group four.
You can even use something like
lead oxide or tin oxide.
Even they will donate
oxide ions.
In fact, you can put a lot of
lead oxide in, you'll modify
this thing so much that it'll
start to allow you to cut
crystalline facets and this'll
be called lead crystal.
Why do we use lead?
Well, number one, it modifies
so I can cut it and I get a
straight line instead of that
conchoidal glass edge that if
you've ever cut yourself you'll
never do it again.
The other thing is lead, because
it's got so many
electrons, has a very, very
high index of refraction.
So when you make your billion
and you've got your crystal
chandelier hanging, of course
you want the cut crystal with
a high index of refraction
because it's going to make
that candlelight look
really elegant and
romantic and so on.
And if you make a super boatload
of money, then you're
not going to go with
lead crystal.
You're going to make diamond
pendants, right?
Because they've got
a higher index.
And we all want the best
index, don't we?
OK, so I think this is probably
a good place to stay.
So let's jump to the end,
because we've got
a few things here.
So I said I was going to show
you about metallic glass.
Here's metallic glass.
1959, Pol Duwez, who was a
professor at Caltech, reasoned
that if he were able to cool
liquid metal very quickly, at,
say, a million degrees per
second, he could freeze the
random orientations of atoms
in the liquid state and
prevent them from finding even
something, either simple
cubic, body-centered cubic,
face-centered cubic lattice.
So he worked with
gold silicon.
Gold silicon has a very,
very deep eutectic.
Even though gold melts to over
1,000, mixed with silicon, it
gets down to about 400
degrees Celsius.
So he dropped this through
a little orifice here.
This is molten and it drops
onto a water-cooled copper
wheel spinning at a
very high speed.
And it makes a ribbon some
tens of microns wide.
And what came out here
was disordered solid.
It was metallic glass.
This was the birth of rapid
solidification, and this is
metallic glass.
This is metallic glass.
This has no long-range order,
no grain boundaries, no
dislocations, but it's
not transparent.
Why?
Because it's a metal.
And what do you know about
band gaps and metals?
And it's different.
It was a different Q-factor.
It has different mechanical
properties.
It has no ductility in
a classical sense.
This is just for
your reference.
This is aluminum foil.
And you know what aluminum is.
It's got ductility.
It's got no grain boundaries
so the corrosion properties
are different.
It's got no magnetic
wall boundaries.
So that a transformer made of
this stuff is half the mass of
a transformer made of
crystalline glass.
It has some other uses.
So it's used in magnetoelastic
resonators for theft
prevention-- oh, I'm sorry.
I'm in Cambridge.
I can't say theft prevention--
for inventory control.
And so you see that it's 20%
boron and all of this metal--
iron, chrome, and moly--
and they put this inside the
object in the store.
And then there's a permanent
magnet there,
iron-cobalt-chromium, that sets
the metglass to a field.
And then when you walk through
the uprights, there's a
58-kilohertz signal that causes
this thing to ring.
So it excites and listens
for the ring.
And if you still have that
little piece of metglass in
there that hasn't been
demagnetized--
Bing!
And then, oh, jeez, I'm sorry.
I really am.
I meant to pay for this.
Explain it to the
police officer.
All right.
So that's inventory control.